and finally new rules since eighty
countries in the world have elected a
woman leader but not the United States
of us yet we must admit that when it
comes to being progressive we are often
late to the party
and if you need further proof this
Sunday which is Mother's Day think about
the fact that when my mother was born
women in America could not vote my
mother not some far distant relative I
discovered in ancestry.com my mother who
was born in 1919 the year before women
got the vote of course by the time she
had me in 1956 thanks for women had
really changed how much I'll leave that
to Rex Harrison to explain he played
professor henry higgins when my fair
lady opened on Broadway in 1956 edit Rex
women are irrational that's all there is
to that their heads are full of cotton
hay in rags there nothing with
exasperating irritating vacillating
calculating agitating maddening and
infuriating hags
and he's the hero but that was how women
reviewed in the 1950s irrational pouty
vain thin-skinned hysterical and just
not that bright does that sound like
anyone we know today whoo-hoo
yes Donald Trump who says that if
Hillary Clinton was a man she wouldn't
get 5% of the vote and if Trump was a
man he'd stop whining like a little
[ __ ] this is a guy who actually brags
about his prowess at whining I am a
wider and I'm a wider and I keep whining
and whining until I win
yes it's the I Love Lucy school of
diplomacy does anyone fit the
stereotypical fifties description of a
woman better than Donald Trump any
cringe-inducing line they ever said
about a secretary on Mad Men is true
about Trump and yet he's the one with
the penis and we know that because if
you make fun of it he'll be up all night
tweeting about how great it is he
accuses megyn kelly of being menstrual
but for him that time of the month
is always
has there anyone ever been anyone more
thin-skinned I made a joke about his
father being an orangutan once he
marched into court with his birth
certificate and sue me because he's a 1e
little [ __ ] and if he's not suing you
if he's not suing you he's threatening
to sue you we're demanding an apology
you're threatening to spill the beans he
did that a few months ago when he was
still battling Ted Cruz and someone
posted a picture of his wife he didn't
like so he tweeted he'd spill the beans
about Ted's wife and then literally told
the press he started it just like Teddy
Roosevelt would do yes a billionaire in
a United States Senator and the girls
shower throwing tampons at Kerry I sure
hope this man gets elected so the world
respects us again and I mean this in no
way to disparage vaginas but what a
[ __ ] I mean who gets more hysterical
than lady Donald Trump seeing Mexican
rapists everywhere oh my soul my soul
sweet we must build a wall a giant wall
and bet all the Muslims
it makes Lindsey Graham look like Vin
Diesel
this isn't presidential it's Glenn Close
boiling the rabbit and like the Daffy
typical housewife of the 50s lady Trump
is the one who can't balance a checkbook
Trump airlines Trump casinos Trump
University Trump steaks he's got the
Midas touch if every time Midas touch
something it exploded I couldn't I could
go on but instead I'd like to turn it
back over to Rex Harrison to sum it all
up
why is thinking something women never do
and why is logic never even tried
straightening up their hair is all they
ever do why don't they straighten up the
mess that's inside
never forgets lady Trump that Hillary
Clinton was born a woman
but you chose to live your life as a say
it with me won't you whiny little [ __ ]
which is why if Hillary is the
Democratic nominee I'll be voting for
the only one who has balls
you